Democrats and Republicans condemn Maxine
Waters but is she the future Plus
president from throws one hell of a
rally in the Supreme Court helps out
President Trump on the travel ban I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
so many magical things happening in the
world we'll discuss all of those magical
things in just a second first of all and
let you know that on Monday July 2nd 7
p.m. Eastern we will be joined in studio
by Jordan Peterson to celebrate
Independence Day daily where God king
Jeremy boring is hosting a new edition
of daily wire backstage with me and
Andrew claimant and the execrable
Michael moles to look back on our
country's birth and look ahead to its
future subscribers will even be able to
write in live questions for us to answer
on the air so that is Monday July 2nd
7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific with
our special guest Jordan Peterson and
you can find our special live stream on
Facebook and YouTube so don't miss it
check it out and subscribe so you can
ask us your questions also before we get
started I wanna say thanks to our
sponsors over at the u.s. CCA so how
would you like to hit the range tomorrow
with a brand new gun you are a
law-abiding Second Amendment loving
citizen and that means that you probably
should own a weapon to protect yourself
protect your country protect your family
protect your community well the u.s. CCA
wants to give you a free gun right now
they are giving away a different gun
every single day this month this all
ends on Friday so you're almost out of
time just go to defend my family now
calm and you can get entered right this
moment you could get up to 17 chances to
win your gun every day it could be 17
kimber 17 Glocks maybe even a Sig Sauer
but they are all gone on Friday so all
you have to do is go to defend my family
now calm to reveal the gun you could
take home today it is totally free but
again not a lot of time and the gun of
the day always disappears at midnight
and this ends Friday so again defend my
family now calm to get entered to win
your free gun right now to defend my
family now calm the USD see I provide
you all sorts of great services
educational services legal defense
services in case you actually have to
fire your gun and somebody god forbid
defend my family now calm is a great way
to register with the US you see a plus
right now when you do that you ensure
you have a chance to win seventeen
chances to win a gun defend my family
now.com defend my family now calm
alrighty so the breaking news today is
that the Supreme Court has upheld
president Trump's travel ban it was not
a travel ban according to the Trump
administration but it was a travel ban
for particular countries there were
seven different countries from which
travel was essentially banned because we
could not vet people who are coming in
from those countries in a 5-4 decision
the Supreme Court on Tuesday upheld
president Trump's temporary travel ban
affecting several countries recognized
as state sponsors of terrorism according
to emily Zanotti over a Daily wire Chief
Justice John Roberts wrote the opinion
and it appears both justice Neel Gorsuch
and Justice Anthony Kennedy
the majority Henning president Trump's
Justice Department a win on the issue
the courts language was strong Roberts
wrote the opinion he noted that the
president quote lawfully exercised the
broad discretion granted to him under
Section 1182 F to suspend the entry of
aliens into the United States and the
President of the United States does have
plenary power to suspend immigration in
this sort of fashion for security
purposes the court also noted that the
president's interest in preserving
national security particularly in light
of terrorism concerns overrides concerns
pertaining to the free exercise of
religion has codified in the First
Amendment's Establishment Clause that
was always a stupid argument the
argument that the First Amendment
Establishment Clause applies to people
who are not American citizens so if you
are in Iran and you want to get into the
United States and we say well we're
banning certain religions as bad as that
policy would be as stupid as that policy
would be it doesn't violate the First
Amendment you're not a citizen it can't
just be somebody in the middle of a hill
Afghanistan in Afghanistan and you say
well you're violating my First Amendment
rights you don't have First Amendment
rights under the Constitution of the
United States the court stuck to the
traditional strict scrutiny standard
writing the president must have
compelling reason to over to override
guarantees of religious freedom in the
case of the travel ban it's entirely
possible that the danger of importing
known terrorists or supporters of terror
outweighs potential First Amendment
concerns opponents of the band had asked
the court to apply a rational basis
standard the court did not appear to
agree on the matter even considering the
president's tweet about Islam so there
are all these courts these lower courts
that had quoted President Trump
suggesting that he was a bigot and
that's what was motivating all of this
and the court said listen he can't just
cite a bunch of presidential tweets or
presidential candidate tweets in support
of the proposition that a piece of
legislation is inherently bad you
actually have to show that the
legislation violates the Constitution
this piece of legislation or at least
this regulation from the executive
branch did not violate the Constitution
and thus president Trump's travel ban
stands at least for the moment according
to the Supreme Court's that of course is
a win for president Trump meanwhile the
continuation of the of the mob
discussion is it continues forthwith so
all of the focus on people who are
protesting Trump administration
officials at restaurants and trying to
get them thrown out of restaurants and
and shouting outside of people's homes
and intimidating people in public places
you recall yesterday we talked about
Maxine Waters representative from
California who went out there and said
that you should have mobs basically run
people
gas stations and get them and not to
participate in public life by screaming
at them using these intimidation tactics
a lot of folks on the Left have said
this is a bad idea which is good for
them right that's that's exactly right
these tactics are stupid it turns out
that even the redheaded story the story
about Sarah Huckabee Sanders going into
a red hen in Lexington Virginia and
being turned away with her family it
didn't actually end there according to
Sarah Huckabee Sanders employees at the
red hen then followed her to the next
restaurant where they attempted to
heckle her at a restaurant that was not
their own which as I said yesterday is
even worse than a restaurant owner just
throwing somebody out for politics
actually going to somebody else's
restaurant heckling somebody until they
leave is a is a is close to a brown
shirt tactic and in in public life it is
it is a nasty nasty tactic that has been
used by sort of mobs everywhere in order
to intimidate people into not getting
involved in politics well people on both
sides of the aisle have now condemned
this Sarah Huckabee Sanders yesterday
she slammed Maxine Waters for pushing
for exactly this sort of mob action here
was the White House press secretary
debate on ideas and political philosophy
is important but the calls for
harassment and push for any Trump
supporter to avoid the public is
unacceptable America is a great country
and our ability to find solutions
despite those disagreements is what
makes us unique okay all of that is fine
and she's exactly right the Democrats
top Democrats are saying the same thing
Chuck Schumer came out and Ken condemned
Maxine Waters here's what he had to say
I strongly disagree with those who
advocate harassing folks if they don't
agree with you if you disagree with the
politician organize your fellow citizens
to action and vote them out of office
but no one should call for the
harassment of political opponents that's
not right that's not American okay and
that of course is exactly right good for
Chuck Schumer for saying that the Senate
Minority Leader even Nancy Pelosi the
the house Minority Leader she came out
and said the same thing condemning
Maxine water she said in the crucial
months ahead we must strive to make
America beautiful again Trump's daily
lack of civility has provoked responses
that are predictable but unacceptable as
we go forward we must conduct elections
in a way that achieves unity from sea to
shining sea so she's correct about this
that we actually need to to return to
civility but there is something in her
comment here that is telling and it's
the reefs
we're not going to return disability
anytime soon what she says is that
Trump's daily lack of civility has
provoked responses that are predictable
but unacceptable this is all Trump's
fault
a mentality that suggests that lack of
civility on the other side is the real
problem generally allows people on your
side to act with lack of civility so
there's a lot of good psychological
studies that suggest that if you believe
you are a victim you are more likely to
act out against somebody else every
victimizer believes at root that they
are a victim Hitler believed that he was
a victim of the world he believed that
the Jews were victimizing his country
and so he was therefore justified in
acting out very rare that you find
somebody who's an aggressor who doesn't
claim that they were acting in some sort
of vague sense of self-defense
well this is what Democrats are doing
now Democrats are basically suggesting
that Trump started all of this and Trump
meanwhile is suggesting that Democrats
started all of this now I think the
Democrats got uncivil long before
Republicans did I think they were deeply
uncivil during the Bush administration
when they're calling Bush Hitler I think
that President Obama was uncivil in the
way that he was fomenting riots in
places like Ferguson Missouri and
Baltimore Maryland but does that and
does that mean that we have an excuse
for exacerbating the incivility I don't
think so because the bottom line is that
we can now have this reactionary
back-and-forth of incivility across the
political aisle as long as we want to do
it I just don't think that's gonna make
the country better in any way but my
argument is likely to lose because I'm
saying that we should take a moral high
ground here that we should take a stand
in favor of civility that even if
somebody is attempting to protest you
and destroy your and destroy you by
going into a restaurant and yelling at
you that this is not an excuse for you
to do the same thing to people on the
other side of the aisle I understand the
tenor in popular perspective right now
and this is how you have entire
political parties that are captured by a
base so while you have Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi condemning Maxine Waters I
really think that Maxine Waters is the
future of the Democratic Party in just
the same way that you saw Democrats
during 2008 2012 2016 suggesting that
Bernie Sanders was too radical and then
Bernie Sanders took over the entire base
I think the same thing holds true here
Maxine Waters is channelling the most
extreme side of the Democratic base and
that extreme side of the Democratic base
has a lot of emotion behind it and even
people in the mainstream of the
Democratic Party they may disagree with
the tactics but they agree with the
sentiment and so I think Maxine water
it's in the end he's probably gonna win
this one in the long run I don't think a
return to civility is in the cards
anytime soon
here's Maxine Waters who is expressing
exactly what I'm talking about blaming
Trump for her own nasty and evil actions
here why the president chose to stretch
that out and and try to imply that I was
causing harm as a matter of fact the
president calls for more violence than
anybody else but let's not talk about
that
okay so Maxine Waters again saying that
it's totally okay for her to call for
violence or mob action because Trump she
thinks called for violence or mob action
then President Trump has responded
basically in kind right president Trump
has suggested that there would be
consequences for what Maxine Waters had
to say that there'd be backlash none of
this is good stuff and as I say I think
Maxine Waters represents a serious
portion of the Democratic base and the
most passionate portion of the
Democratic base and the part of the
Democratic base that a lot of these
politicians like Schumer and Pelosi
eventually will have to bow to so for
example John Legend who is I think more
representative of the base in many ways
the Nancy Pelosi he tweeted out let's
make a deal with the Trump
administration reunite all these
families immediately and you can go out
to eat whatever the bleep you want in
other words do what we want or we're
going to use tactics of intimidation and
John Legend is of course a very popular
figure simul and Sanders on CNN she said
yesterday that all these people who are
talking about civility including Nancy
Pelosi including people like Chuck
Schumer the only reason they're talking
about civility is because civility is
just another instance of white privilege
there is something to be said about that
the folks calling for civility might
need to check their privilege and so
where's the civility in the press
briefing room Jake where is this ability
at the border for these children and so
and this conversation about civility is
completely one-sided and skewed how is
it one-sided and skewed going into
restaurants and shouting people out of
restaurants going in people's homes and
protesting outside their homes how
exactly is that skewed why is that an
element of white privilege it seems to
me that of all the people in the United
States who shouldn't like mob action
black folks should be high on that list
considering how mob action resulted in
in tremendous suffering for black people
for literally a century and a half in
this country I think then that then
makes no sense to me well yeah the worst
instances of mob action in this
country's history have been actions that
were taken in the in the Jim Crow South
during the 1910s 20s and 30s and yet
Simone Sanders says
to oppose that to oppose mob action is
some sort of white privilege I just I
don't see that at all I don't understand
how that works
Ashley Nicole who Ashley Nicole and
Nicole black she tweeted something out
similarly this is a tweet 15 this is a
writer I believe for Jimmy Kimmel and
Sheree oh hello I didn't see you there
civility is a tool of white supremacy
okay cool bye which is a weird tweet
that I should tweeted that out some
Samantha bee right or rather civility is
a tool of white supremacy no civility is
a tool of having a decent Republic we
can't have a decent republic if we can't
have conversations with one another but
again I think that the capture of the
base is nearly complete I'm gonna talk a
little more about that in just a second
first I want to talk about what you
should be doing to protect your money
and one of the things you should be
doing to protect your money is allowing
somebody who really knows what to do
with money to help you handle your money
that's what betterment is for they're
the largest online financial advisor
they're designed to help customers build
wealth plan for retirement and achieve
their financial goals their mission is
to help customers make the most of their
money they take it complex investments
investing strategies and these
technology to make them more efficient
so I have a financial advisor I send all
my money to a financial advisor my
financial advisor does all sorts of work
for me and then I never have to think
about my money again
that's what betterment is there to do
for you they have low fees nowhere do
they have hidden costs no matter who you
are how much money you invest you get
everything for a low transparent
management fee and advice is also in
your best interests as a fiduciary they
make recommendations and clients best
interest they're not incentivized to
recommend particular funds they don't
have their own investment products to
sell over at betterment and they'll
provide you tools to help you understand
how you're doing so they offer
personalized advice a suite of tools to
help you know whether you're on track to
hit your investing goals or get the
retirement you want if you are young and
you're planning for the future there is
no question you should have a financial
advisor and betterment helps make it
easy ben shapiro show listeners can get
up to one year manage for free for more
information go to betterment comm slash
shapiro that's better mint.com slash
apparel can be tter m ENT comm slash
capiro use that slash capiro
you get up to one year manage for free
betterment comm slash shapiro check it
out okay so as I say I think there's a
lot of talk on the Democratic side of
the aisle from the leadership about
let's not get violent let's not engage
in this sort of mass action let's not
get uncivil but I don't think that
that's the way this is gonna go I think
that incivility is now seen as a tool of
the passionate
civility is seen as a tool of the
establishment if you are civil if you
are decent to other people because our
politics has gotten so contentious this
means you don't care enough and we now
gauge our politicians not along the
lines of what they get done or how
effective they are we gauge them along
the lines of how much they care we see
authenticity and anger we see
authenticity in rage we see authenticity
in you going out there and shouting at
the moon this makes you a more authentic
politician Nancy Pelosi sees fake Chuck
Schumer is fake but Maxine Waters she's
real she's aunty Maxine she has daddy
Maxine sitting around your kitchen table
telling you how you ought to go to a gas
station and harass somebody until they
leave so I have my serious doubts that
this genie can be put back in the bottle
and by the way I'm not sure that the
genie can be put back in the bottle from
the right because there are a lot of
people on the right who are calling for
civility today a lot of people on the
right who are suggesting that we need to
be more civil to one another and that is
not the the tenor of the Republican
Party at this point that is not the
tenor of President Trump that is not the
tenor of a lot of the people who are big
fans of President Trump the thing they
like best about President Trump is that
he is uncivil again because they think I
think rightly so that Republicans have
been punched so often they need someone
who's going to punch back the problem is
there's a difference between punching
you can punch in civil fashion I know
that sounds contradictory but it's not
you can be polite and still say things
that really gut the opponent and then
there's punching wildly and making the
civil society worse and I think that's
more what President Trump tends to do
like I'm not sure how this is
particularly helpful Trump supporters
were in a rally yesterday and they
started yelling go home Jim and Jim
Acosta now I think she Mikasa is an
idiot right I mean I think that he's
terrible I've talked about on the air
many many times but the kind of revelry
that surrounds this these sort of
triumphalism that surrounds shouting in
a reporter go home Jim I'm just not sure
how that makes the country better in any
significant way we'll be here later on
tonight campaigning for the man who
wants to be the governor of South
Carolina for another four years at his
hand
master and as you can hear behind me
wolf the crowd is very firing up we have
about a couple thousand people in this
room so far they are letting the press
corps here know exactly how they feel
about what we're doing and it is
certainly true that the press has been
awful for President Trump the press has
been just garbage all the way across I
mean I've covered it in detail but I
think it is possible to criticize the
press strenuously without without the
country basically turning into two
groups of people screaming at each other
at the top of their lungs standing five
inches from each other's faces spittle
flaking them I just don't I don't see
how that makes the country a better
place now
so I think that you know what we're
seeing in South Carolina that rally is
quite the same thing as going into a
restaurant and harassing someone until
they leave I don't I don't think it's
quite the same thing but the temperature
has been raised in the country to a
point where I'm not sure the temperature
can be can be simmered down any time in
the near future and again I don't see
either party attempting to really do so
so in just second on to talk about
president Trump's actual rally in South
Carolina and again like I think that
President Trump is channeling something
I don't think the President Trump is the
great driver of incivility in this
country what you're seeing today is a
lot of people on the Left Pelosi Maxine
Waters saying the Trump is the one who
made politics uncivil as I said before I
don't think that Trump made politics
uncivil I think politics has been
uncivil since cindy sheehan was standing
outside george w bush's ranch and
screaming at him that he had murdered
her son I think politics has been
uncivil for at least the last nearly 20
years I think the politics has been
really uncivil since maybe the mid 90s
Meimei probably most likely after the
2000 election it got really uncivil I
think and then it's and then top-level
politicians have channeled that anger
and instead of saying to people the
hardest thing in politics to say is your
anger is unjustified or your anger is
justified but let's try to treat each
other well right those are two very
difficult things to say in politics much
easier to say to people that anger is
justified that your anger is righteous
that your anger is good and president
Trump is great at channeling this stuff
he's terrific at it right it's his
specialty so for example yes and he's
very funny too I mean just on an
objective level the man's very funny so
yesterday at his rally president from
slammed Stephen Colbert and Jimmy Fallon
and Jimmy Kimmel
listen I've slammed all three of them I
think all three of them have done a
piss-poor job at actually being funny as
opposed to being political but the press
kind of rabble-rousing off their back
I'm not sure that this is what the
President of the United States should be
doing per se even if I enjoy it as a
partisan as a partisan I may enjoy the
fighting but as an American I think
you'd be better if we had more of a
civil society being built as opposed to
being torn down what a lowlife
what a lowlife I mean honestly are these
people funny there's no talent he's not
they're not like talented people Jimmy
Kimmel no talent but I'd go to a studio
to do a shot you know to do a thing he
would stand outside on the sidewalk
waiting for me oh here he comes Donald
Trump Oh Oh sir how are you so thank you
so much for doing Jimmy Fallon calls me
up and he's like a nice guy he's lost he
looks like a lost soul right he gets out
there hey oh but you know what he's a
nice guy I agreed to do a show what is
it a year and a half two years later
he's now apologizing because he
humanized me and he really hurt himself
so I said to him today on social media I
said Jimmy be a man just relax just
really so two things can be
simultaneously true one Trump is
hilarious or I mean this is the funny
funny stand-up routine him going after
all these comedians - this is really
great for our civil discourse is the
kind of stuff that you want to see the
presidents of the United States saying
probably not now listen I know I know
that inside Republican circles we've all
taken this for granted this is who Trump
is this is what Trump is going to be I
get all of that but to pretend that it's
not having any impact on our civic
discourse is to I think be foolish okay
it is having an impact on our civic
discourse doesn't mean that Trump is the
great driver of the collapse of civic
discourse no I think that he is a
response to the collapse of the Civic
discourse that had already been
happening again in 2012 Joe Biden was
going around saying that MIT Romney
wanted to put black people back in
Chains and the entire left was
suggesting that MIT Romney had given a
woman cancer specifically so that he can
make her husband lose her her health
insurance so incivility has been a part
of our politics for a long time but
there's no question it's getting a lot
worse the left I think is leading the
way but the right to reactionary nature
is driving a cycle of incivility I think
that's fair to say I think what we have
right now is a cycle of incivility and
what it's going to take is one group
saying listen I know you guys are being
simple I know you guys are being jack
I get it but guess what I'm not gonna be
a jackass just because you're being a
jackass I'm gonna point out that you're
being a jackass but I'm not going to
call for any of these sorts of tactics I
think it's wrong to call for any of
these sorts of tactics in fact these
tactics are what make you a jackass in
the first place if you think this is the
thing I don't get from the left they
left his saying well Trump started all
of this the reason you don't like Trump
is because he said all these things so
your responses to be him your response
you you think the thing Trump is the
worst of all possible worlds you think
Trump is so uncivil and he's so untoward
and he's so gauche so your response is
to imitate him your response is that all
of the things that you hate about
President Trump are the things you now
want to be this is this is why you you
have a politics that is spiraling and
disarray and on the right you're saying
the same thing people saying well if the
left's gonna do that well why shouldn't
the right do that why unilaterally
disarm maybe one thing if you're saying
we're gonna use this tactic in order to
prove to the other side this tactic is
not worth using a mutually assured
destruction that's not what's really
going on what's really going on on the
right is an attempt to hijack the tactic
because hey turnabout is fair play
it's more of a revenge play than an
attempt to make the country better we
need to make the country better now with
all of that said there are some people
who are going too far in this direction
suggesting that incivility and politics
from President Trump and the right it
means that Republicans should vote for
Democrats David Brooks is the latest to
make this case so today David Brooks in
The New York Times has a long piece
calling for conservatives to avoid
voting for the Republican Party this is
asinine
okay so will you'll recall George will
claimed that Republicans in Congress had
abdicated their duty to check the
executive branch and Democrats would do
a better job ignoring the Democrats
would be stymied by a Republican
minority and that the Democratic agenda
has moved wildly to the left
well David Brooks argues that
conservatism is being undermined by the
Republicans and by President Trump how
well he argues the conservatism is about
protection of the order that pre-exists
Liberty so there's a great argument in
conservatism over whether conservatism
is really primarily about Liberty or
whether it is about the idea of order so
to take it to a philosophical level
there's an argument between Locke and
Burke right this is the argument that
that I think David Brooks wants to set
up so John Locke suggested that human
beings could be governed by reason and
that we had certain inherent inalienable
rights and these rights were life
liberty and property and the rights of
freedom of thought was one of those
rights and that if we all got together
in civil society with a small
that would be the best way to run things
and Edmund Burke said listen all the
stuff about rationality is just fine and
it's just great but we have to
understand that without civic
institutions that inculcate virtue
liberty is bound to devolve into
libertinism of a free society with no
rules and people are bad people then
things are going to decay really really
quickly so what you need is a social
order that pre-exists Liberty without
the social order that cannot be Liberty
and so the argument seems to be sort of
that conservatism is more about the
social order than it is about Liberty at
least that's what Brooks is arguing so
he argues the conservatism is that about
the protection of the order that
pre-exists Liberty the maintenance of
what he calls the sacred space necessary
for the Liberty to thrive he can't he
contrasts the Enlightenment mentality of
reason and consent with the Burkean
notion that such concepts unmoored
from shared cultural history and
institutions run amok so Edmund Burke
was a famous British jurist not a judge
but he was Member of Parliament and he
famously wrote against the French
Revolution suggesting the French
Revolution had given up on the legacy of
the West in favor of Pure Reason and
that it would students evolved into the
guillotine of course he was exactly
right so here is what Brooks writes he
says the practical upshot was that
conservatives have always placed
tremendous emphasis on the sacred space
where individuals are formed this space
is populated by institutions like the
family religion the local community the
local culture the arts the schools
literature and the manners that govern
everyday life over the centuries
conservatives have resisted anything
that threatened the sacred space okay
all of that is true right we are all
defenders in the conservative movement
of family religion local community local
culture the arts good literature
civilization right these are all things
that we believe ought to be protected
but here's what Brooks goes wrong he
believes that the market is what has
undermined all of this so he argues the
Conservatives only value small
government because they think that big
government is going to violate family
and violate the social order but if big
government didn't violate the social
order everything would be just aunty
so he says conservatives fought big
government not because they hated the
state per se but because they loved the
sacred space the last attempts to build
a conservatism around the sacred space
or george w bush's compassionate
conservatism and in Britain David
Cameron's Big Society conservatism
they both fizzled because over the last
thirty years the parties would the right
drifted from conservatism so he says the
Republican Party is no longer a
Conservative Party because it no longer
cares about the social
order instead it only cares about market
fundamentalism and he says market
fundamentalism is an inhumane philosophy
that makes economic growth societies
prime value and leaves people atomized
and unattached and this is untrue market
fundamentalism is the basic idea that
you own your own labor and that's market
fundamentalism it is not the idea that
growth in and of itself is the great win
right that's that's a utilitarian view
of the market market fundamentalism is
about the idea that markets in and of
themselves are moral which they are if
you get to own your own labor then the
market is moral as opposed to government
regulation of that market which is
generally immoral because it is
violation of your ownership of your
labor and your time but Brooks says
Republican voters eventually rejected
market fundamentalism and went for the
tribalism of Donald Trump because at
least he gave them a sense of social
belonging at least he understood that
there's a social order under threat
again I think this is a dramatic Mis
reading of American conservatism this is
why Brooks distinction between Locke and
Burke is wrong during a hard line break
between Locke and Burke is foolish hey
george w bush's conservatism was flawed
not because he cared about social
institutions but because he didn't care
enough about market fundamentalism the
founders believed in the notion of
individual liberty but they also
believed that individual liberty could
only thrive when people were virtuous so
you actually needed social institutions
to fill the gap left by government so if
you want to take care of each other
we're going to need churches we're gonna
need groups where we get together if you
want to have kids who grow up healthy
and strong and form families you're
gonna need social institutions that help
foster all of that liberty and that and
that's what allowed there to be liberty
right because if you create a bunch of
good human beings you can leave them
free to do anything whereas if there are
a bunch of bad human beings you can
barely leave them free to do anything
and liberty and order were originally
seen in the american bargain as two
sides of the same coin brooks however
separates the two and he says that free
markets are inherently non conservative
which is not true at all and then he
says that americans swung to trump
because trump was a substitute for
market fundamentalism which of course is
not true either most conservatives voted
for Trump because he wasn't Hillary
Clinton and while Brooks is correct that
we've now substituted a certain level of
tribal politics for our social
institutions
he's certainly wrong that such tribal
politics are a response to market
breakdown what has actually happened in
the United States is not that the market
has taken over everything what's
happened in the United States is that
social institutions destroyed themselves
because there was a
forced attempt to destroy those social
institutions in the name of libertinism
not in the name of markets in the name
of social freedom in the name of I
should be able to do whatever I want so
I agree that we're seeing a breakdown
into tribal politics I agree that social
institutions and and social capital has
degraded but I don't think that has to
do with market fundamentalism and so
here's where Brooks he comes out so
Brooks this whole column has been
written in order to say that you should
not vote for Trump and you should not
vote for Republicans here's what he says
he says in 2018 the primary threat of
the sacred order is no longer the state
yeah that's a pretty radical statement
he says it's a radical individualism
that leads to vicious tribalism the
threat comes from those two main
currents of the national Republican
Party and his essence Trump is an
assault on the sacred order that
conservatives hold dear the habits and
institutions that cultivate sympathy
honesty faithfulness and friendship so
Trump is contributing to the breakdown
of the social order
therefore Republicans should not vote or
conservatives should not vote Republican
because Trump is contributing to the
breakdown of social order but that's not
correct okay there are two sides to
Liberty one is small government which is
inherently good because again the
government does not have a place telling
you what to do and the other side of
social order even if I agree the
President Trump is helping contribute to
a breakdown in the social fabric which i
think is arguably true even if I think
that is true that does not mean I'm
going to turn to the Democrats who have
forcibly attempted to destroy the social
fabric wholesale right to say that
Democrats ought to win people who have
been anti family who have been anti
Church who spends all their days trying
to come up with government legislation
to destroy the social order to say
that's a better solution than voting for
Republicans is simply insane but Brooke
says today you can be a conservative or
a Republican but you can't be both and
then he says that the places where he
sees that most the the future of the
country are Burlington Vermont and Salt
Lake City
okay well that that's pretty amazing
thing to say considering that Burlington
Vermont has a total population of 42,000
people if median family income of 76
grand and an unemployment rate of 2%
yeah it's easy enough to say that's a
nice place when it's a nice place the
real question is what is going to
reinstitute social fabric Trump isn't
gonna do that Democrats aren't going to
do that but that doesn't mean that you
sacrifice the social fabric to people
who forcibly want to just destroy it I
mean look I I don't think Trump has been
a force for good when it comes to the
social fabric but
I think that Trump at least still likes
the American flag I think there are
certain aspects of the social fabric
Trump is still in favor of the Democrats
simply are not free markets are not
killing social institution lack of
social connections are killing social
institutions and again the Democratic
parties have much greater threat to the
social fabric at this point than the
Republican Party even as much as I hate
watching the Republican Party
threatening the social fabric at all I
think all that's a mistake it's in just
a second don't talk a little bit about
president Trump's tariff plans he's now
attacking Harley Davidson plus I want to
talk about a New York Times op-ed that
explains what I mean about the
destruction of the social fabric and why
David Brooks is wrong first you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wired.com and
sign up so for $9.99 a month you too can
get a subscription to daily wire comm
when you do you get the rest of this
show live you get the rest of the
clayvin show live the rest the normals
show live and you get to ask questions
in our mailbag plus we're having that
big hubbub on July 2nd with Jordan
Peterson you can ask questions then too
if you subscribe you get for 99 bucks a
year you get this leftist cheers tumblr
as well that's left is tears hot or cold
tumblr it's cheaper than the monthly
subscription and and again you get all
of the aforementioned Grande benefits
please go over to our YouTube channel
and subscribe as well go over to iTunes
leave us a review we always do
appreciate it we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so here is why I think the David Brooks
is so wrong headed when he said and
George will when they say vote for the
Democrats to stop presidents from first
of all I think Trump's agenda has
largely been good not universally but
largely been good and second of all I
think that trying to suggest that Trump
is going to be more destructive to the
social fabric than Democrats ignores
exactly what the Democrats are doing
right now okay so on Monday the New York
Times ran an op-ed from a guy named
brian at w van Norden who is a professor
of philosophy at Wuhan University Yale
and US College in Vassar College calling
4d platforming of all conservative
dissenters why because those opinions
are bad of course so the same people
that David Brooks are saying you should
vote for those people are saying we
should deep platform anyone who
disagrees with them there's a reason
that the left is so comfortable at David
Brooks these days so Norton in this New
York Times op eds he juxtaposes
worthwhile opinions with non worthwhile
opinions here's what he says he says
worthwhile opinions quote include
historically informed argument from tana
he see Coates that structural racism it
makes the American dream possible and
the nuanced thoughts of Capeman
a professor of philosophy at Cornell
University about the role of hemp
a--they in supporting misogyny like
sympathy but for him get it uninformed
arguments according to this professor at
Yale include arguments from jordan
peterson taken wildly out of context so
Jordan Peterson should shut up but we
should hear from Donaghy C codes who
said about 9/11 that he watched the
planes hit the buildings and felt
nothing because he was smoking pot on
the rooftop and we should definitely
listen to the arguments of Kate man who
nan ironically uses the word him pathy
if you not ironically use the word him
pathy I think that pretty much suggests
that we should not listen to you on
pretty much anything but according to
according to this Professor we should
ensure that people like Jordan Peterson
or Ann Coulter they should not be able
to speak publicly so here's what Norton
writes he says we may feel certain that
Coulter and Peterson are wrong but some
people feel the same way about coats and
man and everyone once felt certain that
the earth was the center of the solar
system if this specious line of thought
seems at all plausible to you it is
because of the influence of on Liberty
published in 1859 by the English
philosopher John Stuart Mill Mills
argument for near absolute freedom of
speech is seductively simple well his
his argument for near absolute freedom
of speech is simple because it's correct
basically he says if it's a true opinion
it should get a hearing if it's a bad
opinion then we should susat out we
should actually treat with it and figure
out why it
bad opinion but Norton says that's not
good we shouldn't have freedom of speech
really because freedom of speech relies
on the rationality of human beings and
as we all know human beings except for
this guy are stupid
he says he's smart so he should decide
what you get to hear but everybody else
is really dumb here's what he says as in
the pages of the New York Times again I
mean this is this is this is thought
tyranny he says the problem with Mills
argument is that he takes for granted
and ieave conception of rationality that
he inherited from Enlightenment thinkers
like Rene Descartes of course mill and
Descartes disagreed fundamentally about
the one his story historical rational
method which is one of the reasons for
doubting the Enlightenment dogma that
there is such method and this is purely
idiotic it is like saying that because
Christianity and Islam disagree about
the nature of God there is no God and
throwing out rationality because
Descartes and mill disagree is just like
that you can't throw out rationality
just because two people disagree and
indeed it turns out that Norton doesn't
think that rationality is wrong at all
he thinks that he is the only rational
person so he should do all your thinking
for you he says the problem is that
humans are not rational in the way Mill
assumes I wish it were self-evident to
everyone that we should not discriminate
against people based on their sexual
orientation but the current vice
president of the United States does not
agree well first of all I think that my
times probably does agree with that I
think that if he mike pence owned a
restaurant he would have gay people at
his restaurant he says I wish everyone
knew it is irrational to deny the
evidence that there was a mass shooting
in Sandy Hook but it syndicated radio
talk show hosts can make a career out of
arguing for the contrary right there are
some people who act with less
rationality than others this is not an
argument against rationality and it's
certainly not an argument in favor of
shutting down the political process
because once you're arguing against
rationality folks once you're arguing
that the that the individuals in the
United States are incapable of
discerning true from false that they are
incapable of understanding decent
argumentation there is no purpose to a
republic at that point at that point you
may as well just have an aristocracy run
by professors from Yale who get to
decide what you see in here and indeed
that's what this professor then argues
he argues that free speech has become
the tyranny of the majority and instead
of John Stuart Mill he quotes German
American philosopher Herbert Marcuse
okay Hart Marcuse is one of the most
evil philosophers of the latter half of
the 20th century he's the guy who
originally coined the term make love not
war he's also the guy who suggested a
theory of what he called the repressive
tolerance Marcuse mark uses theory of
repressive tolerance was that if we are
tolerant of everyone
viewpoint than in fact we are
strengthening bad viewpoints so she we
should simply suppress viewpoints that
are of the right he openly said this
Marquess and now he's being quoted in
the pages of the New York Times by this
professor as a counter to the argument
that liberty is good here's the quote
and endlessly dragging debates over the
media the stupid opinion is treated with
the same respect as the intelligent one
the misinformed may talk as long as the
informed and propaganda rides along with
education truth with falsehood and the
professor says this form of free speech
ironically supports the tyranny of the
majority so in other words we should
shut up everybody that this guy
disagrees with who does he want to have
talk more he says he'd like to hear more
from know I'm Chomsky the the political
simpleton who has sided with every
repressive dictatorship of the of the
latter half of the 20th century he says
that we should hear more from Noam
Chomsky now do these sound like the
kinds of people that you want to trust
with the social fabric this is the kinds
of people who say that Herbert Marcuse
was right about free speech but John
Stuart Mill was wrong these are the kind
of folks you want to trust that's why in
all the talk about civility which i
think is beneficial and we should return
to a certain level of civility we should
try to have polite conversations with
one another we shouldn't lose the
distinction between left and right in
the in the battle over civility civility
should apply to left and right but right
ideas are better than left ideas because
left ideas when it comes to civility
there's nothing more uncivil than taking
the government and forcing your point of
view down somebody's throat with the
point of the gun okay meanwhile
President Trump is going after Harley
Davidson
yeah I've been saying since before Trump
was actually inaugurated that president
Trump's government interventionism when
it came to the economy would eventually
rear its ugly head and it was bad I got
a lot of flack for saying that I'm sure
I'll get a lot of flack for saying it
again but tough on Tuesday president
Trump was obviously stung by reports
that Harley Davidson the iconic
motorcycle company would be moving some
jobs overseas in response to president
Trump's tariffs on aluminum and steel
which have raised the cost of inputs in
Harley Davidson motorcycles as well as
in response to new European Union
tariffs that are replaced as a reaction
to president Trump's tariffs so
President Trump took to Twitter and
started savaging the company so here's
what he tweeted he tweeted earlier this
year Harley Davidson said that they
would move much of their plant operation
in Kansas City to Thailand that was long
before tariffs were announced hence they
were just using tariffs trade war as an
excuse
unbalanced an unfair trade is but we
will fix it okay that is not true okay
they announced that they would move some
of the plants operations in Kansas City
to Thailand having nothing to do with
tariffs but that's not the same thing as
what they're saying now now they're
saying they're moving jobs into Europe
yes it's a completely different thing
and then he says when I had Harley
Davidson officials over to the White
House I chatted them about tariffs in
other countries like India being too
high companies are now coming back to
America
Harley must know they won't be able to
sell back into us without paying a big
tax to now he's talking about taxing
Harley Davidson out of existence because
of his own stupid trade policy and then
he said a Harley Davidson should never
be built in another country never their
employees and customers are already very
angry at them if they move watch will be
the beginning of the end they
surrendered they quit the aura will be
gone and they will be taxed like never
before okay if you think this is in any
way remotely conservative you are out of
your mind this is not conservative okay
to target a company because they are
making an economically feasible decision
in response to government intervention
ISM to target them and suggest that they
surrendered and they quit and the aura
is gone and they are gonna tax the hell
out of them it's obnoxious
it was obnoxious when Obama did it too
by the way all right this is the second
time in two days that Trump is attacked
Harley Davidson yesterday he said that
he was surprised that Harley Davidson of
all companies would be the first to wave
the white flag he said I fought hard for
them and ultimately they will not pay
tariffs selling into the EU which has
hurt us badly on trade down a hundred
and fifty 1 billion dollars taxes just a
Harley excuse be patient well no Harley
Davidson is moving because tariffs are
bad for a lot of companies in the United
States they're a net job loser and they
impact lots of companies but what Trump
is talking about this is white Trump at
heart is not a free-market a free-market
guy again he's cut regulations he's
given us tax cuts I'm very grateful to
President Trump for a lot of his for a
lot of his policies but he is not a free
market guy when it comes to trade and
it's very obvious from these tweets ok
this sort of language precisely mirrors
the sort of language that Barack Obama
used when he was slamming companies for
taking economically feasible action in
response to Obamacare so remember in the
aftermath of Obamacare being passed a
bunch of companies said they were going
to have to drop man hours so they didn't
have to pay for the full-time health
care of all their employees or they were
going to have to cut jobs then Barack
Obama responded by ripping into specific
companies including staples he said when
I hear large corporations that make
billions of dollars in profits
trying to blame our interest in
providing health insurance as an excuse
for cutting back workers wages shame
online and then he said I haven't looked
at staples stock lately or what the
compensation of the CEO is but I suspect
they could well afford to treat their
workers favorably and give them some
basic financial security and if they
count them they should be willing to
allow those workers to get the
Affordable Care Act without cutting
wages okay so he was ripping into
staples
why because staples was responding in
perfect market fashion to a terrible
economic disincentive Obamacare and I
said at the time it's just like
Democrats it is just like government
interventionists to create garbage
government policy and then companies
respond to that garbage government
policy and then they say well if only
you were a little more patriotic then
you wouldn't respond to our policy this
way it's like when Joe Biden said back
in 2012 that companies that are big they
should be patriotic and pay more taxes
I don't gauge my patriotism by paying a
higher tax rate I'm paying a hell of a
lot more in taxes than I paid even five
years ago I'm not more patriotic now
than I was five years ago just as I am
paying a lot more taxes I'm just getting
screwed by the government harder okay
probably so are you so this idea that
that Trump is putting forth that
harley-davidson is being unpatriotic or
unamerican by responding to his bad
policy is stupid and counterproductive
maybe the policy is just bad government
intervention ISM has an unintended side
effect and that is not the fault of the
companies that are responding to those
unintended side effects by attempting to
to save jobs and save their company all
right time for a couple of things I like
and then a couple of things that I hate
so let's do a thing that I like so you
may have missed this story but in Iran
there's actually a bunch of protests
taking place there's been these these
protests that taking place economic
insecurity is roiling Iran the regime is
would be on its last legs if it were not
for the the Obama administration signing
billions of dollars over to the Iranian
mullahs in their evil evil government
here this is an amazing thing crowds in
Iran
we're chanting yesterday and what they
are actually chanting is death to
Palestine not a joke
not death to Israel death to Palestine
listen to this
I mean that's unbelievable because all
we've been told forever is that the
Muslims Street hates Israel that Muslims
across the world despise Israel they
don't want to make peace with Israel and
that if it weren't for Israel everything
would be hunky-dory Barack Obama bought
that line too I mean he said in his
speeches that the core of all Middle
East politics was the israel-palestinian
issue here are the people of Iran saying
no that's not the core you guys are
sending money to Hamas and Hezbollah
that money should be staying here that
money shouldn't be spent on terrorism so
when they're chanting death to Palestine
what they are really chanting is death
to the regime that is that is giving
money to terrorists all over the world
in order to kill Jews that's an amazing
thing and thank God we have an
administration now that actually wants
to foment this sort of uprising because
that's what it's gonna take its gonna
take actually an uprising in Iran and
what it really is gonna take
realistically speaking is somebody
inside the Iranian military who agrees
with a lot of the protesters and
launches some sort of coup because if
not then the moles will just know these
people down in the streets unfortunately
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so this is a truly amazing story
California is now considering creating a
fake news advisory group in order to
monitor information posted and spread on
social media not a joke is according to
CBS local Sacramento
Senate bill 1424 would require the
California Attorney General to create an
advisory committee by April 1 2019 it
would need to consist of at least one
person from the DOJ representative from
social media providers civil liberties
advocates and First Amendment scholars
the advisory group would be required by
the California State Government to study
how false information is spread online
and to come up with a plan for social
media platforms to fix the problem the
left is fully convinced that the reason
they've been losing elections is because
of fake news it can't just be that
people think their arguments are garbage
it has to be fake news it has to be the
people are being deceived and thus we
need to regulate speech in just the way
that this New York Times op-ed writing
Yale professor was saying that we need
to regulate speech state of California
wants to regulate speech too state of
California is already moved in this
direction with their educational policy
they're attempting to move in this
direction with their non-discrimination
policies suggesting that if people like
me say in the state of California that a
man is a man and a woman is a woman then
we ought to be fined now they're
cracking down even harder they want to
have the government determine what it's
making new
or not it's hard to think of anything
more Orwellian than the government
determining what sort of news ought to
be covered that is deeply Orwellian
stuff if Donald Trump were doing it the
left would be crying Nazi right now buts
the state of California doing it so we
have to pretend this is all about
tolerance and diversity hell radical is
this bill the Electronic Frontier
Foundation which is a left-wing group
opposed the bill calling it flawed and
misguided the group argued the measure
would make the government an advisory
group responsible for deciding what is
true and what is false and it points out
the First Amendment prevents
content-based restrictions even if
statements are admittedly false so it's
just another indicator that when when it
comes to gaining political power the
left has no compunction about using
governmental censorship in order to
achieve their ends that's why as much as
I like I just like the incivility that
is evidence in our politics right now
I'm not gonna pretend that left and
right are exactly the same across the
spectrum in the way that George will and
David Brooks seem to want to right now
okay we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest updates I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire Ford publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018